hello and welcome to our nevada extreme
weather virtual press conference
featuring nevada assemblywoman rachelle
nguyen
of district 10
reno city council member devin reese
and assistant director jody bechtel of
the clark county department of
environment and sustainability
along with climate justice and public
health experts who have come together to
speak in support of significant
investment in clean energy to address
nevada's climate crisis
i want to thank the nevada conservation
league for sponsoring today's event
for our agenda we will have two to three
minutes of formal remarks from each of
our speakers
who will be visible and audible via
their video
at the end of the formal remarks we will
have a brief session for questions
related to today's event
and members of the media will be able to
raise their hand or use the chat
function to indicate they have a
question
i would like to now introduce angeline
dybala the communications director for
the nevada conservation league
angeline the microphone is yours
thanks so much ashley and good morning
everyone i'm angeline tabalba the
communications manager at the nevada
conservation league
now here at the nevada conservation
league we envision a future where all of
our communities can thrive because we
have access to a healthy climate future
so i'm glad today you all could join us
this morning with some elected officials
climate activists and other health
advocates to talk just about another
crisis threatening our livelihoods and
devastating our communities
climate change
now climate change is inducing extreme
weather events across the country and
nevada is on the front lines
these record-breaking temperatures
out-of-control wildfires historic
droughts now if we fail to act boldly
and quickly we can just expect these
things to get worse
now this week and continuing in today we
are seeing the calder fire race toward
lake tahoe
now prompting the evacuation of nearly
50 000 residents from their own homes
last week our federal government
declared a water shortage at lake mead
one of our nation's largest reservoirs
for the first time ever
and according to states
at risk.org reno nevada is the fastest
warming city in the entire country and
these temperatures are expected to rise
over the next decade
so climate change is making extreme
weather events more frequent more severe
and nevadans are paying the price
these disastrous events are ringing
alarm bells and they're calling on us to
take bold action and immediate action on
clean energy climate jobs and justice
now there's an urgent need for congress
to pass a budget that makes bold
investments in those places
now we need a clean energy future
that creates millions of family
supporting clean energy jobs
that builds resilient communities and
reduces pollution that is already
fueling these climate disasters to begin
with and threatening public health
so
now is our moment to go big
to be bold and to put people at work
so we're asking u.s senators catherine
cortez masto jackie rosen along with
congressman stephen horsford to continue
leading and
expanding clean energy
so we're also grateful to congressman
stephen horsford for his leadership in
this space and his recent commitment to
supporting the climate priorities in the
build back better budget
so this means we need to support a
budget that makes investments to cut
pollution to create jobs address
environmental injustice and tackle the
climate crisis right now i'm happy to
introduce assembly woman rochelle nguyen
of nevada's district 10.
hi there um good morning or good
afternoon i am assemblywoman rochelle
nguyen i represent assembly district 10
in the nevada state legislature
i'm proud to be a member of one of the
most diverse legislatures in the nation
and i know that the diversity of
representation creates better policy
we've seen time and time a day again
communities of color are hit first by
the ongoing and worsening climate crisis
whether that's experiencing increased
rates of health issues due to extreme
weather wildfires pollution and smog or
bearing a larger financial burden in
response to extreme weather events or
being forced to live in neighborhoods
that are disproportionately affected by
urban heat islands our state's
marginalized communities are too often
left behind i've seen this firsthand
i grew up in the pacific northwest and a
lot of times people don't think of
extreme heat but obviously extreme
weather and extreme climate change
they are seeing it firsthand up there as
their temperatures reached 116 degrees
this year
i remember i am the child of a daughter
of a refugee and working class parents
and i watched my parents work multiple
jobs just to provide for my sister and i
growing up in our house we had one of
those single window air conditioning
units and it struggled to keep even the
one room cool during the summer months i
remember on those really hot nights my
entire family would cram into that room
and sleep there and try to find relief
from the heat so unfortunately i do know
that my experience is not unique
something that many families across the
nation and throughout nevada have
experienced first hand
it's time to pass that build back better
budget to make them much needed bold
investments in our clean energy economy
clean energy infrastructure and to build
a more resilient energy grid address
these environmental injustices
and reduce
pollution that is driving these intense
and dangerous extreme weather events
nevadans and families like mine are
asking for this bold action the build
back better budget will help our nation
and help our state build a smarter and
more equitable infrastructure
i hope that you will join and my family
for our congressional representatives to
support the build back better budget
thank you for your time
thank you assemblywoman nguyen and
councilmember rhys
yeah thank you hi friends
let's see what we can accomplish here
uh thank you so much for uh
participating today with uh all of the
groups and also our media partners
my name is devin reese i'm the reno city
council member at large and i apologize
we were having some tech difficulties
there and my remarks are not quite as
polished as my colleague
assembly member when
the week's been a challenging one i'll
just be honest with you
here in the truckee meadows up north in
reno nevada we've had i think now 59
days of compromise air quality
that air quality has been driven largely
by two fires that are larger than the
state of rhode island
and those fires are at minimal
containment today and so
each day as a council member i know the
effects of climate change are impacting
our community the western united states
is
literally today on fire and i can't see
the mountains that are the home to so
many of us here in northern nevada so
i'm a little emotional and it breaks my
heart to say it
but we know that climate change is human
caused and that it will have to be
human solved
technology is not going to dig us out of
the hole we're in but it's going to be
all of us and groups like nevada
conservation league who are leading the
effort and congress with their build
back better budget
that are going to be the way forward i
think a lot about
my own children's future i'm the father
of three and these are young people who
are very critical about
you know the state of the planet that we
as parents have left them in
and it has been a long time coming and
in my role as a city council member we
think about things like water shortages
we think about how do we support our
firefighters in wild
life fire situations we think about how
does growth develop the trajectory for a
community where cars are one of the
largest impacts to carbon footprint and
carbon causing emissions
these are the things that happen on the
front lines and i think uh the
resiliency that has historically been
built into the system has all but gone
and so now we have to ask ourselves as
communities how do we make sure that
communities of color our most
marginalized communities are are not
being left further and further behind
because of the effects of climate change
and i think that the way we do that is
by having smart legislatures in our
legislature in carson city it's by
having smart elected officials in
washington like the members that you've
represented here today and we make sure
that they understand that
where we have been is unacceptable where
we are today is heartbreaking and the
only thing we can do is chart a bold
future and that whole future will be
built with the help of folks who are on
this call and with all of us so thank
you very much for allowing me to
participate and we've got a lot of work
to do
thank you council member
next is jody bechtel with the clark
county department of environment and
sustainability jody
hi thank you ashley and good morning
everyone
i appreciate the opportunity to join
this discussion today because we are
seeing the impact climate change can
have on clark county's air quality
as clark county's air pollution control
agency the department of environment and
sustainability implements strategies
with our business community to control
pollution levels by issuing permits that
hold them to strict control measures
within the environmental protection
agency standards however despite these
efforts we can still experience poor air
quality through circumstances outside of
our authority like vehicle emission
standards and circumstances beyond our
control like drought and wildfires
rising temperatures have led not only
reno but las vegas to be called one of
the fastest warming cities in the u.s
according to climate central
in fact three of our five hottest years
occurred from 2016 to
2018. so extreme weather events are
becoming our new normal and have
contributed to increases in ozone and
particulate pollution in southern nevada
wildfire smoke influences ozone
formation and particulates in the air
and we've seen a direct correlation with
poor air quality days especially in four
of the five
i'm sorry four of the past five years as
the wildfires in the west have gotten
worse
last month alone due largely to wildfire
smoke we experienced one of our worst
augusts on record for ozone exceedances
of the environmental protection agency's
health-based standards
right now we're nowhere near what reno
is experiencing and our hearts do go out
to that community
in an effort to address climate change
impacts in clark county we launched all
in clark county which is an initiative
to create a sustainable community for
current and future generations in
southern nevada
tackling issues such as clean energy
infrastructure urban heat island effects
and environmental equity
but working at the local level alone
only addresses one portion of a much
larger challenge we need more investment
in climate change solutions at the
federal level we need bold action from
congress
long-term planning and investment at the
federal level must become the new normal
thank you and now i will pass it to
reverend leonard jackson executive
director of the faith organizing
alliance
thank you and thank you ashley for uh
bringing us together
uh no explanation is needed because
times and our lives and our welfare is
on the edge of a cliff and it's up to us
to come together to pour ourselves back
from the edge
so
my name is reverend leonard jackson i'm
the
executive director for the faith
organizing alliance here in
las vegas
uh
we came into being here in in the
business here in the state back in 2014
and why because we realized that our
people
especially people of color were hurting
24 7.
uh it was nice to come into our
community to register people to vote to
find housing to find food etc but when
we look around we realize that we have a
water shortage
fire is out of control
uh storms are raging the heat is
unbearable then we know that we need
help in our community and we're not
going to say that help is on the way
because help is here
i want to personally thank our elected
officials especially uh congressman
stephen horsford who has dedicated his
ability to help us with our energy
solutions here within our community and
i say thank you to our governor because
he opened the door for us he opened the
door that
nevada can be number one in the energy
field but it takes us coming together in
unity to make a positive change we
realize that history has a way of
telling the story to tell them the truth
because we realize that our communities
of color and low wealth communities are
the first ones that are hit with
devastation whether it be fires
homelessness unemployment our health is
poor uh we can go down the list that
we're there but we know one thing for
sure that the governor signed the right
energy bills this time around to make a
difference and put
this state on the map and put them in
place of number one and we're gonna move
up just a little bit higher because
we're coming together when we look at
buildback a better budget here in this
state then we're gonna make that
difference here in this state but we're
gonna stand tall and stand for something
but we do not want our children to look
back at us
and say there's stood some foods but we
realize that we are a community that
will stand together that will make a
difference we'll stand up speak up and
move us forward and that's why we are
here today understand this
faith organizing alliance and how we
really truly got involved here because
we want to make sure that we have the
right bills in place
okay to make a difference and we realize
that yes the money is there the ability
is there but it's up to us again to come
together which we are doing so this way
when our children look back they'll say
out our parents and our poor parents
stood for something didn't fall for this
in the old thing i'm gonna stop right
there while i'm ahead because we're
going to make sure that the bills and
energy bills especially that will pass
and it says that 40
percent of that money will go to the
underserved underprivileged communities
well as long as faith organizing
alliance is here in this community we're
going to make sure that the so-called
underserved underprivileged community
will benefit from that 40
of the funding will come directly to our
community train our people for the jobs
that are out there and uplift our
community let the church say amen
thank you so much reverend your message
about unity and collaboration as we
tackle the climate crisis could not have
been stated any better and i'm glad you
took us all to church on this message i
want to say
thank you so much to assemblywoman
nguyen council member rhys um jody
batchell um and reverend jackson again
for joining us to chat about just how
devastating climate crisis is for all of
our communities now climate change is
making these extreme weather events like
heat waves droughts and wildfires that
we've talked about a lot more dangerous
in nevada and we're feeling those
effects of climate change and we need
the strong investments to help mitigate
these effects before it can get any
worse
now fortunately our state has taken
action on climate like reverend jackson
had stated that we've established some
strong climate goals to get to net zero
emissions by the year 2050 and 100 clean
energy by the year 2050.
now this year um our state legislature
also passed a major clean energy bill sb
448 to strengthen our grid reliability
and create more electric vehicles
charging stations and even make sure 40
percent of funding
goes to those low income and low wealth
communities
now any federal investments in a climate
resilient and renewable energy future
would just add to the critical funding
already underway in nevada and help us
get to further heights to achieve a
healthy climate future
right now as congress negotiates this
major bill to help rebuild our
communities climate and clean energy
investments need to be prioritized
but don't just take that message from me
take it from the 83 percent of voters
who actually are concerned that future
generations will be more impacted by
extreme weather events in their
lifetimes compared to today
or from the 77 percent of nevadans who
agree and favor the historic investments
in climate and clean energy that
president biaden had promised
now today nevadans are calling again on
u.s senators catherine cortez masto and
jackie rosen along with congressman
stephen horsford to support the build
back better budget and make those bold
investments to tackle the threats posed
by the climate crisis
time is running out and nevadans need
our elected officials to act now on
climate clean energy jobs and justice